hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special
guest my aunt janet
she is when i think of um a very like
feminine woman and like a woman who
really like made all the right choices
when it comes to dating i think of my
aunt janet
yeah um but what's my real name
what's your real name oh summer james
summer janet yeah
um so before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel i'm trying to
get to 20 000 subscribers that is my
goal this month and each and every one
of you
help while you're at it ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos oh i'd love to ring a bell
it's like on youtube like it's a oh i
wish i had my cowbell i'd be doing it
yeah to advertise okay okay go on okay
so um i wanted to ask you so
tell them a little bit about your
husband and your family and how
like that started okay so i lived in a a
pretty big town
in dubuque iowa okay and we moved to
potosi wisconsin
so i went from a class of 500 to a class
of 30 to 40. okay one hallway instead of
a big high school
and um i was walking down the hallway
and i saw the cutest guy i was a junior
he was a freshman
and i fell in love it was instant love
it was like a candy store i'm like who
is that cute guy and so another day
i was walking down the hall and i said
hi
and he did not say anything to me i'm
like what what
he ignored you yeah he didn't think uh a
junior would be talking to a freshman oh
he was a freshman
okay and so um a friend
on the football team said that they knew
that somebody liked him
okay and told them and um
so the next day he sat at the table the
lunch table with me i just about died
oh so he like came up to you then when
he found out you were exhausted yeah
okay
and then um so you were how old you were
16. um
i was a junior in high school so what
would that make me
17 no i would have been yeah he was 15
i was 16. okay cool yeah
and so then his mom's like what is this
dubuque girl doing with my little baby
and he had just gotten dumped from his
girlfriend in the summer on his birthday
and he came home and he was so excited
that high school was gonna be good
how long did you guys date before you
got married so eight years
okay and then we um waited six years
before we had children
i was 30 years old when i had a child so
did okay this kind of personal question
did you have to force him to marry you
or was he like oh my gosh
no let me tell you so
he came from a family of nine kids when
i met him he said i want to have
ten kids and i looked at him hannah i
said
you gotta get a different woman i'm not
gonna have nine kids
so then we had one kid and then he said
two was fine
okay so what did you feel like attracted
what it what
attracted you to jason and what did you
feel like you did right to attract him
to you
oh because it's not just it's not just
getting a man it's like keeping a man
right right so i think what attracted to
me was his looks
okay he was good-looking okay yeah
and so then i think what the core thing
is he's a good christian man
okay so hannah you need to find a good
person that believes in god whatever
religion it is it's okay
but they don't marry an atheist because
it will go
it won't go so well yeah um
so you need to find somebody who
believes in god and has morals
okay otherwise they're gonna cheat on
you wow
yeah is that like super common you've
seen have you seen a lot of your friends
get cheated on
um no um when our first friend group
they got divorced i was just
devastated i was depressed for two weeks
really yes because they seemed like the
greatest couple
they seemed happy but there was cheating
involved i think when people don't have
a faith-based
then there's more room for cheating do
you um
have you found like what do you feel
like you did
right that your friends didn't
um because obviously like cheating is
one thing but there's stuff that leads
to cheating like i don't always always
put it on the cheater because a lot of
times there's
stuff that happens before would you
agree with that or disagree
that what so um what i'm not
i'm not saying that like it's okay to
cheat i'm not saying that the blame is
like obviously that's 100 their fault
um but what i'm saying is usually like
when there's cheating it's not like
that's not the only problem in the
marriage
like i would oh you know what i'm saying
like usually there's other stuff too
would you agree with that or disagree
i'm young that's just outside looking at
i think so
but i think that if you have a good
faith-based
then you're going to say
this is the morals that i'm going to be
committed to this person
and the honesty is important like
jason's a very honest person
and he has good common sense i can think
about a problem for two weeks
and dwell on it and he will know
instantly what to do
so now i just ask him so that i don't
have to worry about it for two weeks
and um it's interesting because what
they always say on the channel like in
the manosphere this is what i call it
which is like men's dating advice
they say woman um if you want they call
it a high value man
and a high value man is like somebody
that makes six figures for
three years or more he has to have a
network of like men that are also
successful
he has to have um he can't have kids
like out like with other women
um oh my gosh they're gonna roast me
because i could never name all five
um but i'm getting better but like
basically like the biggest thing is the
six feet like a guy that earns a lot of
money
i totally disagree with that totally
disagree really
yes money does not buy happiness you
could be
a billionaire and be depressed you could
be sad your life is in shambles
money does not buy happiness so you
don't think that do you okay because no
no no no no this is what i'm going to
ask i was a mental health nurse
for 10 years and i saw all kinds of
people have trouble
the poor the the rich and
you really need to just have your morals
and values so this is actually the
question i'm going to ask you did you
know that
80 of divorces are filed by women
and did you know that not if you go to
college educated women it's 90 percent
and do you know what the number one
cause is what financial
financials like when the husband loses
his job really
a lot of the time the women like file
for divorce so and are the women working
um or are they just um living it up
so this is like a problem i'm not even a
problem this is just
there's a lot of very frustrated men
because they feel like women just want
their money
yes and they just like that's all they
want they don't care about them as a
person and the second they lose their
job
they're gone then they don't want that
woman anyway yeah that's the wrong
person well that's what they talk about
like this dating
like um content talks about because they
say like
there aren't as many like there are lots
of pretty women there's not a lot of
successful men
so they say like don't um this is just
like the man of sphere does that make
sense
so they say like don't like they just
seem like
if she wants to leave letter basically
like don't don't chase her
don't um do you think that's like false
do you think that's true
i think there's a problem if a woman is
only with a man for their financial
stability
i think the woman has to have her own
job and her own work
unless she wants to be at home and raise
the children okay
you see what i'm saying yeah i agree
with you i think there are a lot of
people that use men for their money and
that's wrong
and they probably don't have good
honesty and core values
and i think you could pick up on that
how how can they
like what what advice would you you have
a son
what advice would you give to roman
about picking away
well i think um they have to have a god
a god based again they have to have some
belief in god
do i i want them to go to church every
week i know sometimes they don't
that's okay a lot of times when people
go to college they stop going to church
but then once they have children again
they might go to church i think they
need to
um find somebody that has positive
energy
and that kind of reiki vibe that
exuberates from them yeah you know
right um and they can boost that other
person up
okay you know i think you have to have
that give and take
but people i think i think guys know
when a girl is using them but they might
just like that pretty person on their
side
so say look at me look at me my
self-esteem is good because i have this
pretty woman who wants me for my money
right and they should not settle because
life is too short
wow that's really good advice so how do
you think do you think
um basically you think it's easy to spot
when girls just want their money
i think so see i don't think it is you
don't no because
otherwise i don't think the divorce rate
would be so high
i think you could say that person is not
that into me
are they making time to be with me what
are you doing together
is it just to do high dollar things then
it probably isn't a good relationship
wow or is it just
hanging out somewhere and being together
and talking the communication is the key
too um
and people really don't know how to
communicate i wish they taught that i
wish they taught parenting school
classes in school um oh gosh i have so
much to talk about
no you can keep going i think you're
gonna be a very interesting perspective
because
um i think the more like i and like
other people watch the manosphere you it
kind of
warps your world view a little bit you
know what i'm saying you haven't seen
any of that no i haven't seen it so it's
just you're just speaking
i'm not experienced no i'm not no women
don't watch it that's why my channel
does so well
is because it's a girl watching
manosphere and giving my opinion
there aren't many girls they don't want
to watch it because they like
um there are some things that i don't
agree with in the manosphere that really
aren't like they basically teach men to
get all the leverage in a relationship
oh you can't play games if you play
games out you go
out wow yeah no game playing because
then
when things get tough and you're with a
sick child all night
and you have to go to work all day and
and things come up financial stress or
family stress it's going to be bad
and you need somebody that's going to be
a partner one thing that i wish that i
would have picked but i didn't know
i grew up um my mom worked part-time as
a nurse
my dad worked full-time and he would
come home supper would be ready
then he might sit on the couch or go
horseback riding or do his thing at
night
and my mom catered to him okay so i
grew up thinking i needed to cater to a
man
really yes well they actually in the
manosphere they teach girls to do that
that should not be because i wish that i
would have
i didn't know like jason never hardly
changed a diaper
maybe four diapers in his life but he
works
all the time he's a workaholic so we
made the balance together
you know um but i wish that i would have
picked a partner that helped with the
housework that helped with the child
care
because it would have been a lot easier
growing up but my generation saw
mothers doing that like i still pack my
husband's lunch every day
yeah but for me it's like a sign of love
yeah like i'm doing this because i love
you
thank you for working so hard and making
money oh
i want to tell you this yeah go off
topic so
um my husband jason i love him with all
my heart and i have a son named roman
he's um almost 16. but they're kind of
not very organized
and they like leave things around
i want to just say this they're slobs i
hope they don't get mad but they are
and they used to leave socks laying
around i get so
frustrated hannah but i had to change my
mindset
and i thought these socks are i love you
notes
so i would pick up a sock and i'd say
roman loves me
jason loves and it really changed i
never got mad about it i just did it
right
well that's something and so you got to
change your mindset and think good
things and i jason has gotten more
organized over the years
and i've helped him because i'm really
ocd and perfectionistic
and my daughter is just like that mm-hmm
yeah she's just
roman is just like his dad and that's
just how they're wired
now that doesn't mean to say
i can go in the shop and tear apart a
motor or a radiator
i can't do that so they have skills i
don't have right
so i'm not like putting them down i'm
just saying we all have our talents
right but find somebody a good man
or am i giving men advice both okay
a good man and a good woman that have
good communication
and do not play games like if
somebody buys something then the other
person doesn't need to buy something
so what i'm saying yeah because you do
it out of luck like you shouldn't be
doing things like
keeping score right because you'll know
you'll never win no
no you just have to be um calm
cucumber calm is like what i like to say
and i never was that way until
the whole covet thing okay i just kind
of felt this inner peace
and mojo in me and what is really
important in life
and it's people not things or
a money okay i would not want to win the
lottery
i would not want to be a millionaire
because i
would not know who my friends are and
then what if somebody kidnaps my kids
i'm happy with who i am and i don't want
any more
dude do you think we're at risk to be
kidnapped well you could be
hannah somebody could get you oh i hope
not
remember that time you were in the
walmart parking lot
no yes i don't you were camping out
oh yeah oh then yeah i was scared to
death
i prayed and prayed for your safety i
think you were more freaked out though i
am i was i just about turned you into
your parents
um but that was a journey and a good
memory
yeah um for you right yeah
no i that convinced me i don't want to
live in a van i just
i used to want to like that was my dream
yeah that dream died
that weekend um but i think
too um when you date you need to know
about
how the person grew up and find out how
their parents communicated and got along
and that will give you the signs
of how they know they don't know any
different
you see what i'm saying if there's a lot
of drama and pot stirring
then that's how they're going to be okay
and it you think people outgrow their
parents you think
i think and they can they like can
someone overcome that yes if they want
to change they can
but you can't change them okay if they
continue to have the same
negative behaviors out so
you said you're not too heavy on god no
i am okay
okay when the camera's off you're not no
no no no no
i just said i'm not a holy roller i i've
said a lot about god in this
and i just think you need to have the
the values and morals and i'm really
nervous
um do i go to church every week i try
but if i skip it's okay
um my family said if you don't go to
church every week you're going to go to
hell
and i don't believe that um
but i think that you have to have those
morals and values instilled somehow
and if it's in your home if it's in a
bible school
or going to church whatever you can get
and i think there's many ways to the
same path
um my daughter is going to start college
can i say the college's name yeah oh
she's going to st
norberts and we went and you know what
we started out the orientation with
what we had a uh prayer in the church
okay and that just grounded me and set
me at peace
right it was just a good way to start
out and i think
too for women and men if there's any
sort of
emotional abuse or physical abuse you
just need to get out
what do you describe as like what
emotional abuse have you seen
like like in fact like you said any sort
of emotional
clearly we all know physical abuse is
that that's right
um calling names um
telling them they're nothing just
constantly degrading them
okay or um putting their choices down
instead of helping them so and sometimes
maybe they have a vision or a dream and
they have to learn lessons about the
dream
and they might fail but they'll get up
and go again
and that's okay okay and you just need
to be there and support them
do you think as like a woman um it's
your job to like get on
a man's like ship like them so they talk
about a lot in the manosphere how
um women or men are meant to lead women
are meant to follow do you think that's
true
i think it depends on the personality so
i can be a good leader but i would
prefer to follow
me too actually yeah i i definitely i'm
not super decisive
i think i lead with emotions sometimes
not logic i've always liked being like a
right-hand man
um and i used to actually look at this
as a really like negative thing i didn't
like it because i was over
like like they would pick other people
for captain physicians because of this
but i realized that that's going to make
me good at being married someday
because like i'm very helpful and i'm
always trying to like help people figure
out solutions but i don't i'm not super
like decisive like i don't care
but if you were put in that leadership
role you could step up and do it
yeah i could i'd just rather not right
right me too
so i think it depends on your
personality if you
would rather have the husband follow i
think there's men that
would be glad to join that ship too okay
so i think it's all
based on personalities and finding that
right person i believe there's a right
person for everybody do you believe in
soul mates
yes oh that's so interesting i don't i
do
i think that my husband jason and i we
grew up together
so we had i mean we
you're born into the religion that you
are right and it doesn't make it good or
bad
just because we're catholic doesn't mean
that other religions are bad
um or that you can't change religions um
but i think that we grew up together
and then our we had the same morals and
values going into
what we're thinking sometimes we
disagree and
it's okay it's okay to disagree okay so
i'm going to tell you my opinion on soul
mates and i want you to tell me where
you disagree okay
so i feel like you are 100 in control of
who you date
right yes so i think that you really in
terms of like your soulmate you you reap
what you sow
and this is what i mean so if you're a
girl right and you go around like
sleeping with this guy that guy that guy
that guy that guy
your soul mate might be like turned off
by that behavior and not want to date
you because you're doing that
or like your soul mate and that's why i
say like i really think it's like you
reap what you sow
and like your soul mate is what you
choose to do and
who you choose to date does that make
sense i see what you're saying
so your soulmate could be out there but
your negative behavior
that person can't see you and so because
of your negative choices you're not
going to find yourself well i think
that's why a lot of
women um are ending up like by
themselves
like just because and i this is um
even when i was like in school right and
i was like drinking all the time like
do you think like that's like a super
attractive behavior to someone no
um and that's like what i realized like
later on does that make sense yes
yeah they're not gonna say oh there's my
wife yeah
hannah would be a great drunk yeah she
would be good getting up with the kids
yeah and that's why like um my senior
year of college i just stopped drinking
all together i was like i'm good on this
not just for that but i also started
getting fat so
well i think that's interesting because
um
the teenage years into college people
drink a lot
and it's kind of the rite of passage
yeah it is um my husband
and i um i think we
cho we choose not to drink it's a waste
of money
we're very healthy people we don't want
to have a hangover in the morning
we can go to the bars and and drink
other things and still have fun
yeah um although when my son roman
graduates from high school i'm going to
have a glass of wine with my friend
missy
because it's just a celebration yeah but
i when i drank
when i was 21 i just got all hot i
didn't feel good and i said i'm done
yeah so yeah i know i love
it's a waste of money it is and that's
what like because it's really
fun for like the moment and you can have
a lot of fun nights like in the moment
but then like you do it for six months
and you just feel awful
you do it for a year you just it just
like slowly progressively gets worse and
worse and worse
i think it's important for young people
to have a budget
yeah and um when you can shop on
amazon and get it delivered to your home
that impulse
makes you feel happy for the moment but
it doesn't bring joy
see again the money doesn't bring joy or
the things you can buy it gets old
and i think that if you're gonna be
married you keep a budget
my husband and i kept a very tight
budget and we got our house paid for
in four years because that was our goal
and then we were going to have kids and
not have to worry about money
wow yeah and we like had the dog food we
ate deer meat
we were very frugal and it worked so
cool
yeah that's such a good idea yeah so
so then you weren't even like work like
that's a a stressor so you guys bit the
bullet young right we don't want to eat
i'm gonna do we worked two jobs for a
long time until we had kids
so i think you want to look for a
partner that has a good work ethic
okay because that is helpful they're
going to be a good worker
on the job they're going to be a good
worker in your family life
you don't want somebody sitting on the
couch not wanting to do anything or
moaning and groaning
you have to have a lot life partner that
gets up like your dad
he's got a lot of energy yeah he does
yes my dad's like the jason has it too
he does they're the one um they're very
rare men with that much energy
and that much ambition yeah
yeah they're a very rare breed right
right
women too like there are many women that
like want to do that and i think it was
born
into them their dad had three different
businesses and work was important
yeah and i think um i don't want to bash
the younger generation but i need to
tell you something
yeah i'm really worried about this
generation
because um in high school
kids are doing a lot of sports they're
going on to these
what are those little clubs that you
were in like volleyball clubs yeah
what are they called club club
volleyball
or you mean college sports no and then
they're
traveling traveling okay so then you're
traveling and these kids are not working
they're just doing
sports there's no time to get a job
that's true um and my daughter didn't
get a job in high school but she helped
with our business and helped me in the
house
so she was working my son's a worker
but i think that as society we need to
step back
and put this work ethic in our kids when
in dubuque iowa when they can't open the
swimming pools because nobody wants to
be a lifeguard we have a problem
wow that happened yeah so one week it's
at one pool
the next week it's at the other people
um
have to shut down their businesses
because they're they can't find
waitresses and waiters so
that's a problem why because they get
more money
and unemployment than working really
and the teenagers don't want to do it
because they're in sports
well i think they can't because they're
too busy in sports right yeah i couldn't
and yeah you can't yeah and it's fun and
you
um my daughter learned great leadership
skills she
learned um good teamwork scoot a little
closer oh yes
i just like it to be a little okay okay
just a little better
okay and so i think that's a problem
that we face
and i think sports is good um but we
need to make sure that these kids are
working
yeah that they're doing chores at home
um
i think the parents think i'm going to
give them everything but when they do
that they take away the work
so we need to work do you think i've
actually noticed
um i think that women
actually have become would you agree
that women have become more masculine
what do you think about like masculine
and feminine do you think that's like
important do you think feminine
because i actually see you as very
feminine just in general like i think
you have a very feminine just like aura
um i and they talk about that being
really important for women and dating
like women that tend to have like more
feminine energy
tend to do better in dating and then
like if we're doing like a case study
here that would be correct with you
because you got married like immediately
met your soulmate that's like the dream
right yeah we're lucky we have two great
kids that are very responsible
but we constantly talk to them and
give them advice like brooklyn had a
financial
class and she knew all the stuff they
were talking about because we already
did that
yeah she's such a good friend yeah and
roman is too he's a hard worker
yeah i mean when you work 13 hours a day
excavating
and you come home he does that yeah he
works with jason in the summer
wow yeah that's nice he's really a good
operator do you think he'll start his
own business
i don't know i've told him he can do
whatever he wants okay
so we'll see what he what he does i
don't know if he'll go to college school
is not his thing he likes to be a worker
and a hands-on worker so we'll see well
i think there's more and more money
that's going to be paid to people that
can actually do things
well i know um brooklyn's class she just
graduated from high school
and people are going to be an
electrician a plumber
lineman because we need the workers yeah
and there's nothing wrong
i think this is my number one pet peeve
hannah
people think that kids need to go to
college
yes that's untrue
my daughter brooklyn wants to go to
college and that fits her
my son roman does not and it's okay
but the school um
thinking is everybody should go to
college and i've argued with
people and said he's not going he's
gonna do what he wants to do and if his
choice is to go to college he can
but it's okay and why
why are we saying you have to go to
college
and then we went to this awards assembly
okay i'm going on a ramble am i doing
okay
you're doing cool okay so we go to
brooklyn's awards assembly there's all
kinds of awards for people going to
college
going to technical college but what
about the working man or the
working woman there's nothing why can't
we give them a step
up well and a lot of them are going to
make more money than the people going to
go to college
yeah because they won't have the debt
like genuinely if i
i'm conflicted about college yeah
because i
very much absolutely loved college
sports
that was something i cherish and i hold
so near yeah
and you made good relationships so
college is good for you
right but not for everyone but this is
what i was going to say
if i didn't have to do the school i
don't think that was very helpful to
what i want to do now
i never used my college degree i have a
degree in economics and business
administration
i don't feel like i learned a ton i
don't like i did not like graduate
feeling like wow
i'm so much better prepared i got a
sales job out of school
do you need a degree to do that no and
then after that i'm now i'm doing social
media
time so if it's hard because but it made
you who you are
you matured and you took other classes
that made you a whole person so i agree
with college for you
yeah i think it's just a choice and i
think
that when the world says everybody has
to go to college we should stop and
think and say
no we need the garbage men who are out
there
um day and night in the rain the cold
did you know some garbage men
their toes are um frostbitten
yeah and their feet warmers yeah i think
they do but it's just so
so cold some days yeah i have two
friends that have
um that are working i don't think they
call them garbage men
what are their names sanitation workers
well um
and they work very hard and i'm so
grateful
because who what will we do with our
garbage well um
kevin samuels one of the guy was
actually going to show you he talks
about in his show he has he says like
the we cannot survive
the world could not survive without men
and he says like let's say like you
could have kids without each other right
he's like
society would continue without with men
it would not continue with women
and women should call on that show
getting super mad but when he breaks it
down he's like
they all have the jobs that run society
like garbage like women don't do that
stuff
but power plants they could i've seen
women welders i've seen
i i think that you can do whatever you
feel no i agree but i'm saying like
so if all the men disappeared tomorrow
they wouldn't be able to transfer the
knowledge to women
if 95 you know i'm saying like if 95 of
power plant workers
that would leave like let's say on a
good day i don't even think it's that
high but five percent
of the entire does that make sense yeah
like the society if you're smart you
would just
learn it i don't think so you don't no
no like genuinely no i'm not saying it
like that i just think like
realistically or you don't think they'd
want to
no i think people would start to die off
before they could
like i'm just like being honest like if
you if you wipe out
95 and i think it's higher i think it's
like 98
of an entire industry that runs society
like power plants electrical
plumbing i just don't think women know
enough
about the the processes that like
run society like does that make sense
i don't agree with that no no i think
there's women in every
every workforce there's women police
there's women
engineers no i'm not i'm not saying like
there's not and i'm saying women can do
the same thing yeah
they can work the same jobs i'm just
saying if all the men
like i have an appreciation for men
doing those jobs
because i think if they all disappeared
tomorrow i think society would be a very
different place and i think it would
like
collapse pretty much give me an example
power plant i don't think that you can
wipe out 95 of an entire industry
and not have the industry collapse and
men
work in the industries that like run
society
more than women
i don't know i'm not educated so i'm
just saying like i don't know the
statistics does that make sense like
survival because women tend to work
with people men tend to work with things
that make sense
like bricklaying that's like 98 women
men
yeah i see what you're saying there but
like the only the only point of that
like because it doesn't really matter
that's not going to happen right the
only point is like
the the guy who runs the show feels like
women a lot of days like we'll say men
are trash like white men are the
problems
but he's just saying like you should
appreciate them because they're doing
all those hard jobs that right
aren't right so you're saying like
they're the ones like doing the trial
they're doing these hard jobs that
society would collapse without
okay that does that make sense that's
that was his point and i want to say
how many people give your garbage men uh
gift at christmas yeah or run them up
uh pop or something in the heat of the
coal or the
the you know the warm weather
i do because i appreciate them i
apprecia
appreciate the male lady or the mailman
we need to really appreciate people more
and say i care about you um
i think the bottom line and i've learned
i'm a school nurse now
is you need to say i care about you
and not judge people you have no idea
what they went through
and you need to just build the
relationships
and it works but it does that's so cute
you give them like a little like
pie at christmas no i give them a gift
card
and then i um send it to them you know
like a gift card to
i don't know texas roadhouse or i was
thinking
what if you put it on the garbage can
yeah
that's why i don't do that i just send
it to the spot and i
get their names okay like the first year
i called and i said who's our garbage
man
and our recycling man and they weren't
going to tell me
it's like confidential i said well i
want to send them a christmas
oh they probably never had anyone do no
but you need to appreciate people
yeah i think that's the thing okay this
is the biggest moment
okay i want to share okay okay i
every my slogan is happy day it
is i walk into work and i say happy day
it's going to be a good day
and jason's like oh my god he needs me
in his life to help cheer him up to kind
of keep him motivated
um so every day is a happy day and i
love to give people gifts when they
least expect it
not a birthday not christmas and i'll
just say happy day
today i gave my dad a trap shoot shirt
my son got 98 out of 100
and no i'm state and his name is in the
back of the sweatshirt and i just said
happy day
do you feel like that's helped you stay
married like they're like the unexpected
just wanting to do nice things for him
no i think what our our uh marriage is
based on honesty like i trust him solely
yeah i know he's not gonna cheat because
first of all he's god based
and second of all he has morals right so
i think that and honesty
and one big tip is i don't engage in
fights
wow so he's really hot-headed and and
gets angry
and he'll say janet's no fun to fight
with because i won't
i'll just say you're upset right now
and we never fight in front of the kids
mm-hmm now is not the time
and i'll walk away and i'll say when
you've cooled down
wow yeah and then with great advice and
then we really talk it through
and i think um just saying i'm sorry i
was wrong even with my kids
if um i mean yesterday i might have said
something to brooklyn
and i was just in a bad mood at the
moment
or she got on my nerves and i'll say i'm
sorry will you accept my apologies
and then i'll say are you salty and
she'll be like no i'm good
you know but i think you need to just
say gosh at that moment of time
i wasn't a nice person and deal with it
that's actually one thing they talk
about in the manosphere is to
to avoid women that feel the need to be
right all the time
and like like that's not good in a wife
would you agree with that
right that's going to be hard to live
with somebody that's a know-it-all
yeah that's a know-it-all um and you
can't change a person
my one of my best bosses said you can't
change anybody you just need to let it
go sometimes
and i thought that was really good
advice i was just a young
school nurse and just thought how am i
going to help
help this person you can't could you
talk a little bit more about how like
money
um doesn't buy happiness in a successful
marriage because
the manosphere would say you're wrong
and i'm going to tell you why and i just
want you to give your opinion on this
so they would say you're wrong because
over 250
000 the marriage um divorce rate drops
from like 50
to 25 percent
so like they that they would say that
like money is actually very important
i don't i don't necessarily agree i'm
just so your wife will stay with you if
you have money and if you don't
too bad goodbye yeah so that you would
say you're just with a girl like then
you don't want to be with someone who
just wants you for your money
right you don't want that kind of
relationship because it's superficial
yeah and you don't want to have kids
with that kind of a person yeah
you know what i mean because then if
something happens
they're out the door yeah and then
you're left with a mess
yeah so if um jason lost his job for
like five years you would you'd be with
him for thickens
i would i would i know you were but i
know i'm asking that question but i
already know the answer
i know he's a worker so if the
excavating business took a dump which it
could
with the economy we're probably going to
go into a recession
i'm not going to talk about politics
yeah i don't want to
it's okay um but he could weld
he could he'd find something he he loves
to farm
yeah he is a busybody he would do
something so i know
it would be fine would we be making the
money we are now
no is it okay yeah come here brooklyn
my daughter just came in the room this
is brooklyn audrey frederick
isn't she like a carbon copy and i love
this girl
well we're so um i'm going to tell a
little story get in here
okay so um brooklyn um
is kind of an introvert but she's just a
fun girl
and i'm trying to keep my boundaries
with snapchat and her friends anywho
we're not going to go to that store
i snap with you i know more than
brooklyn sorry
so anywho i think she's going to find
her soul mate because we're talking
about soul mates
oh look at she's eating a cookie oh
really oh
she's going to find her soul mate as her
lab partner in college i am convinced
and she's going to marry that person but
i could be wrong
i don't know um what um
so if you're tell brooklyn five
qualities to look for and a husband you
only have pick five yeah
so number one what do you think i'd say
do not date an atheist okay not not that
there's anything wrong with them
i know atheists very closely mm-hmm but
for a
catholic family not from a cow no
because we're a catholic family
right it could be any anybody
any religion okay so god based
what's the next one hard-working
hard-working did we just talk about that
yeah okay what else
honest honest did i say that okay
brooklyn knows me
okay what else
i don't know trustworthy yeah what about
um communication is there
no longer communication skills what else
one more think about dad and i
boring boring okay
this is what i want to say so when you
have wealth
you can do a lot of different things but
i think that people who are happy with
themselves don't need all that stuff
wow but they can make memories on trips
and stuff but
again the money doesn't buy the habits i
i say this
all the time that the telltale sign um
because you know i only grew up with my
dad so i was like i actually know
like real successful like wealthy people
and i'm like
i can always tell the first tale tell
sign that someone's either gonna blow
all their money
or that they don't actually have money
is the flashy stuff
because my dad is probably the most
successful person i know
right but he doesn't care no like like
he's probably you know he's one of the
most successful people i know
and every super successful person i know
that like makes a lot of money
they don't care they don't need the
flashy like shoes the flashy car the
because
they know like deep inside that they're
secure with who they are and they know
they're hard working
right no like they don't need to show it
off to the world so now you're talking
about self-esteem hannah
yeah if you are good with yourself
inside
then you don't need that stuff yeah yeah
i don't think i've ever seen your dad
like dress nicely
no maybe if he goes to church or like
weather or something yeah i mean he
could improve a little bit
well he has dan the man shirt on today
yeah
yeah
brooklyn send roman and that he's here
he does not want to
oh he doesn't want to come on so what
five qualities would you say roman would
you would it be the same
for a husband and a wife the same
because what did you say
you said hard-working well number one
was what
oh my gosh no not honestly that was not
a bad basis
some sort of religion god based
hard-working
um trustworthy slash honest yeah did you
finish
and then um
what did we say i don't think you
finished okay
we'll find out good communication skills
okay
and um
i don't know i think you have to have
fun too i think
you have to have fun to do things
together and it's okay to do things
apart
okay i think if you have a person that
does not
allow you to have friends okay
that's not good yeah that's a red flag
right yeah i agree you have to have
other friends
and not just focus on that partner okay
oh i don't know if you're gonna keep
going
i need a hug oh let me see oh
i like your hugs you're one of my
favorite people on the planet i was like
i've missed you so much i can't see you
i know
i know it's been the last year has just
been nuts
but i would say this if i we don't do
facetime what do you do with your samson
what is that called oh i do i don't have
a samsung i have an iphone what do we do
facetime i mean you snapchat video no
you when you had a different thing we
did this duo oh google duo yeah yeah
we and she answers the phone every time
don't expose me i'm so busy oh i don't
was i'm not supposed to say you had that
cut that out no no i meant it like i was
like i don't answer every time i'm so
busy
you do i'm so busy
i have i'm like like the busy yeah i
don't call a lot though
i'm not a needy aunt
i'm so busy i'm just playing
you know it's because i was just like i
have so many so much going on
um let's talk about looks okay so
let's say the man is hot or the woman
has had okay
but 40 years from now they're gonna
change
okay they might bald they may have gray
hair so it's really what's in the soul
so initially the attraction could come
from the way they look
right that's what happened with jason
and i i was a teenager
i'm like oh my god who is that cute guy
in the hallway
okay but then you need to make sure that
your soul's aligned
and that you have the same beliefs the
same values
because life is tough you know
when you're working full-time trying to
raise kids
i remember putting two kids in the car
seat and thinking thank god i don't have
to go after a third
i don't know how your mom did it with
all her kids nannies
yeah but um
i don't know i think it's good to wait
and have fun with your spouse
and then have kids so that you know one
another
and then you don't feel like you're
missing out but
i need to tell you one more tip okay
jason's friend when we were had young
kids said you need to have a date night
get a babysitter once a week and go out
and we did that for many years and that
was wonderful
that you need to have your alone time so
that you have energy for
yeah your kids yeah yeah that's
that's actually oh i was going to ask
you do you think um
in the manosphere they really talk to
women about getting married as young as
possible
um oh and the reason they say that is
because the older a woman gets they feel
like the less like
options she has of people to date
because men tend to date younger
um do you feel like that's true would
you like do you see bennett since you
did
marry pretty young like um did you
that question makes sense yeah like
tripping over my words i think it
depends on the individual
some people like my husband are like i'm
gonna get married
i want to marry you and i said i'm not
getting married till i'm done in college
there's no way
oh he wanted that's he didn't know the
office i feel like my girls have to like
twist their guys i know i'm like no not
until i'm done with school
um so i think it's all individualized
and what you feel comfortable with
and some people might know right away
some people want to get married later
it's okay and i think women are having
babies later because they have to get
their career settled
and they're waiting that's okay
yeah they um they really discourage that
in the mana sphere because they just
and i don't know i don't necessarily 100
like disagree
because i have seen a lot of girls
complain about like dating in their
mid-30s
and just how awful it is and i feel like
i can't be completely like blind to that
does that make sense how old are you now
here i'm 24
i'm i'm trying to get married soon
actually i want to get married like
the next four years how many kids are
you gonna have
um i want at least two i don't think i'd
be happy with less than like i don't
want an only child so i need two
um part of me wants four but i always
say i don't know
until you you have like i used to want
four dogs and i got one
and i said i'm good with one yeah maybe
two someday like
i'm not traveling um but it's hard i
think it's hard to say i didn't even
have a kid but i don't believe in only
children
i don't think they should exist this is
i might get slack for this but i just i
feel like i grew up with a lot of
siblings i think there's a lot of
benefits to having a sibling and every
only child
i've met has some sort of only child
syndrome
some last some more but every person
like has trouble living with people has
trouble getting along with does that
make sense yeah so i just i genuinely
would
at least two my heart kinda wants four
but i would be totally cool too yeah so
i wanted two
and then i had brooklyn and i like lost
15 pounds i had three i
or five ivs i just was terribly
sick the whole thing the whole pregnancy
and i said to jason i'm done i'm good he
said you can't have a spoiled brat
i said well then you need to help me
with brooklyn while i'm pregnant because
i know i'm going to get sick
well the second pregnancy i knew what
medicine to take i knew when to get the
ivs
and then i said boy or girl we're done
and i just said if this baby dies i'm
done
i'm done okay i couldn't do it again it
was hard
and he got a boy it was a miracle yeah
he thought it was going to be a girl you
know
so i think yeah you just never know and
then how much help you have
it takes a village to raise these
children yeah and my kids have been
formed by
we live in a very small community so
they have different moms and dads not
even me
you know what i mean that are good
mentors and good role models for them
and so you really need a village and my
mom and dad were very helpful
with my kids when they were young um
would you give the same
husband looking for advice to brooklyn
as you would me
yes okay i was curious if you think it
changes by person or you think that's
just across the board i think it's
across the board
and they need to treat you right and
make you feel special
um and
hopefully they know how to be loved so
they can give you love
i think that's important does that make
sense yeah
um yeah that's all my questions i think
i think that's a good way to end the
video
okay so happy day this is summer janet
i say that because i'm off all summer
and i'm just happy i forgot to tell you
can i add this yeah you can
okay so my family loves summer janet i
cook i clean if roman needs something he
just snaps his fingers i run right up i
have a lot of energy
because when you're working full time
you're tired you get grumpy after a long
day at work
so everybody loves summer janet now she
comes out a little at christmas time but
not too much
but anywho all right we'll end with a
hug happy day